locking them up real good charging good
to go
give me your codes as you can
see
are you all right
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna do a
follow up to my expanse season 6 episode
1 breakdown video i put out a few days
ago this season they're actually putting
out short teaser trailers early enough
that we can discuss those here and
there's also the short they released on
prime video in the x-ray section which i
didn't get a chance to talk about yet if
you've been watching my expanse coverage
then you know i put out a spoiler-free
review of the season but don't worry
i'll be careful not to spoil anything
which honestly i would have been able to
do from reading the books anyway so i'm
going to be talking about everything
that's happened in the series through
episode one i'm going to be talking
about the teasers plus the mini episode
and koala that they put out on the app
and if any of that sounds like spoilers
that you don't want a part of then this
is your chance to leave and with that
out of the way let's get into it
the season six episode two description
reads with an unexpected passenger
aboard the rasanante holden and crew
undertake a dangerous mission that could
shift the balance of power in the war
drummer decides to make an uneasy
alliance philip wrestles with his guilt
so based on what we see here the
unexpected passenger aboard the rossi is
bobby at the end of episode 1 we learned
that abasarallah had a plan that she put
together after getting information from
holden that they discovered the free
navy spottership the azure dragon which
is also the name of the second episode
and if you look closely you can see that
in the opening they need a win they need
something big because right now all of
their ships are pinned to the planets to
protect them from further asteroid
attacks he even saw this illustrated in
the updated opening sequence they can't
go out and try to turn the tide or take
things away from the free navy because
earth in particular is under constant
threat the line about drummer deciding
to make an uneasy alliance is tied to
what we saw in that mini episode she's
talking to someone we just hear a voice
there's no face no indication of their
affiliation but we know that they need
to refuel and rearm their ship and their
options are limited one thing you can
pick up from the first episode is that
even though the free navy may not be
able to feed all their people they are
making progress in going out and
eliminating the other factions that had
gone against marco so the crew of the
tynan is in a tough spot and they're
looking to put michio somewhere safe out
of harm's way after the mistakes she
made that cost them the dewalt and while
we're talking about them let's get into
this anka wallah scene we first heard
the word anka walla in episode 9 of
season 5. this is how oxana referred to
drummer to crawl when they were talking
about keeping the secret about naomi
being alive the direct translation would
be something like anchor person so you
could think of it as a loved one or a
soulmate and initially i interpreted
this as her putting drummer above the
other members of the polyamorous family
but the expanse writers responded on
twitter that she could refer to any of
them that way you see the words one ship
in the opening and in voice over naomi
introduces the belter creed the doctrine
of one ship so drummer is a combination
of different characters including one
that shares the name with her crewmate
here michio paw we get an explanation of
this doctrine in michio's chapters in
the books it boils down to a belief that
there was only one ship and it had
countless parts as a single body had
countless cells she describes it in
relation to the ships that are under her
and how her little fleet is only a part
of the free navy a vast organism that
passed information between its cells
with tight beam and radio that consumed
food and fuel that worked its own slow
destiny among the planets like a massive
fish in the greater sea of the sky she
talks about her extended crew the others
who served under her came and went
respected that she was captain that her
orders were fair and that she didn't
show any overt favoritism to her spouses
but there was the understanding always
that the core of the ship was her family
and no threat to it would be tolerated
the idea of separating family from crew
was an inner planet's thing one example
of the unconscious prejudice that made
earthers and martians treat life aboard
ships is somehow different from real
life for them the rules changed when the
airlock closed even if they didn't know
themselves well enough to see it for
belters there was no division
so it's a belter-centric way of viewing
things from the perspective of people
who live in space the ship is home it's
not something that you use to get from
point a to point b your family your crew
those are all part of a bigger organism
and everyone has an important role in
working together for its survival so in
the clip we see the reaction to the
bounty being raised when they see the
announcement about that as mentioned
before we do see that drummer has made
contact with someone and they're on
route to resupply they've already
explained to michio that she'll be
dropped off when they do that and she
comes in and tells joseph that she
looked inside drummer's hand terminal
and realized that all of her videos were
things that she saved from naomi this in
and of itself isn't a big revelation to
us we know that oxana brought this up
and more importantly the fact that
marco's wanting her to kill the ross and
nantes so it couldn't save naomi is
exactly why she went against the free
navy drummer didn't do that to save
holden considering that she has strong
feelings for naomi her feelings about
her boyfriend are complicated what
stands out here is that she deletes them
all at the end her family suffered as a
result of her decision her husband serge
paid the ultimate price and while
discovering the videos made michio
question her dedication to the family
her deleting them is an indication that
she regrets the way that things played
out what a great character and i gotta
say it's nice to see michio get a hug
here because that was kind of a rough
ordeal she went through in episode one
so it was an interesting look into
drummer's family on the tynan and we'll
have to wait and see how that becomes
important later they are gonna be doing
one of these with every episode i'm not
sure if they're all gonna be like
extended scenes or if there'll be some
other stuff added in but it's a nice
addition and i look forward to seeing
how they go for the teasers they're both
short one was basically a twitter post
and one was more a traditional teaser
and they're both based on the same thing
and kind of go together so i'll just be
looking at it as one big thing and boy
do i love me some action sequences with
bobby and power armor okay even though
it's gonna sound a little ridiculous
there are some things about these
teasers that i can't confirm because of
the do not reveal lists that amazon
sends out when they give you screeners
you can pretty much put together what's
happening here right you don't need me
to spell it out for you the rossi has
tracked down a ship bobby is wearing
said power armor and the other ship is
making a break for it holden is in the
pilot chair doing his best to keep them
close which at one point that looks like
it has amos pinned to the floor under
thrust everyone's in suits and we can
see that clarissa is preparing an emp
device that bobby will be carrying later
the airlock door in the cargo bay is
open and we hear bobby tell holden to
get her as close as she can she then
jumps out with that emp in hand in a
great looking shot as the ships are
flying side by side and is able to land
safely and after she secures herself she
calls for naomi to follow on the rossi
we see naomi start and then she kind of
freezes up and then we hear holden ask
if she's alright and the teaser ends
there we did see naomi jump out of a
couple of ships in season 5. once
without an air bottle and once with no
suit at all neither of those were
pleasant experiences but it's still kind
of hard to imagine that the crew
wouldn't be able to count on their
resident belter in a situation like this
and as i said wow bobby's leap is just
so weirdly satisfying to behold this is
something that is pulled directly from
the books although the setup is a little
different and there's one major change
that jumps out here so this looks like a
great addition and even in these short
compressed for twitter clips the visual
effects look amazing and i'm gonna have
to wait until the full episode comes out
before i can talk anymore about this the
last thing from the episode description
was that philip is wrestling with his
guilt we saw that start in the last
episode and it was a safe guess that
that would continue he's still a young
man and there's a lot of different
things going on here all of which will
be exasperated by the idea that he shot
somebody on ceres someone who was his
friend so that has an extra weight to it
but also this isn't the wild west you
can't just go around murdering people in
broad daylight on top of that he played
a major part in mass murder he's
starting to see that what his father
says and what his father delivers aren't
exactly the same things and if you think
back to episode one each time he echoed
those ideals that they needed to take
care of the people on series because
that was their people that was their
capital he was quickly brushed aside and
it's implicit that he doesn't understand
how things really work but then also
rosenfeld's there she has his father's
attention and he's not getting this
direct education to help him understand
any of that which i mean is a good thing
objectively but that's not how a young
man who defines himself in relation to
his father would see it so i think
that's probably all there is to say ever
since the first teaser came out i've had
a lot of questions about why they
decided to add the laconia part and i
did make a whole video about why i
thought that made sense so you should
check that out but here i'll just say
that i think it is essential to the
story they're telling in this season
plus it's a great little story so enjoy
it for that reason and just hang in
there because i don't think you'll be
disappointed so let me know in the
comments what you think about the season
so far what you think about these
teasers about the x-ray episode and what
you're hoping to see in the next one
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon
you